nous pouvons reprendre le rail et bien
heureusement car j'étais en train de
dérailler merci alors nous allons
reprendre le rail d'ouessant autrement
dit le reportage de jean pierre qui
tarde sur ce fameux rail d'ouessant
oui ce sont les ptt ou c'est la
télévision oui bien alors je pense que
nous allons suivre dans un instant cette
exposition à moins que comme on vient de
me l'annoncer
on nous présente à notre fille nous
allons voir dans un instant toujours un
peu de retard
j'attends des précisions je suis désolé
je ne reconnais pas pour vous oui oui le
japonais je prends désormais un problème
je vais me renseigner auprès de la régie
j'aimerais que vous me disiez ce qui est
ce qui se passe est-ce que après
l'interview de madame françoise giroud
je suis présent et bien oui nous sommes
à nouveau en panne
c'est amusant non nous ne sommes pas le
premier avril donc je vais essayer de
poursuivre ce journal en gardant mon
calme
alors nous allons donc voir
l'inauguration de l'exposition cet après
midi plutôt quelques images avant
l'inauguration
vous n'avez plus rien du tout bien alors
on met la clé sous la porte on s'en va
qu'est ce qu'on fait oui oui non je ne
quitte pas vous ne quittez pas non plus
un mais vous mettez à ma place aussi
merci